tee
[音楽]
uh
今日はいい
[音楽]
仲里隆三と申します
僕は普段映像のディレクターとか
カメラマンをやっています
突然なんですけど皆さんダークマターってご存知ですか
ダークマターって言うんですけど家ようにある暗黒物質と呼ばれる物質でこれはまだ今
観測されてない物質なんですね
でもこの物質がないと今ある理論とか研究が
証明できないないものになってしまう
まだこういう物質が宇宙には90%以上あるんじゃないか
そんなことがやれています
このダークマターというのが僕のあだ名なんですね
大学時代についてはたらなんですけど
なんでこういうあだ名がついたかというと僕大学の頃に
デイドリームシアターという映像制作チームを立ち上げて活動しました
そのチームで活動するようになってから本当悪魔ターっていうあだ名がついたんですね
これデイドリームしちゃった
今日は皆さんにデイドリームシアターの活動となぜ自分がダークマターという場合に
なったのか
菅一体どういうことなのかということをお話ししたいなというふうに思います
僕が映画を作るようになったのは大学に入ってからです
大学で英語を勉強していました
皆さんこう映画というとどういう風に作られてるかって
ご覧になったことありますかね
なんかすごいたくさんの人がいていろんな役割があっていろんな技術のがこう集結して
映画ってのは作られてるんですね
大体こんな感じなんですけど
監督がいてェ
録音とか
俳優がいてたくさんほんといろんなものが集まって映画つの作られています
でも智孝大学に入ってからいろんな役割をやりながら映画を作ってたんですけどなんか
だんだんと鯉が感を感じるになったんですね
映画の
作り方というかそういう役割みたのになんかこうアウェイなアウェーな感覚を覚えよう
になりました
これなんだろうっていう風に自分で考えた時に
なんかそういう役割がある中でだんだんと
1100バリン作業それがすごく機械的なものに覚えてきたんですね
僕がすごいそれが嫌だったんですっていうのも映画というのは何かおもしろいことを
面白いと思える人とすごい一緒になって情熱を傾けられるそういうものが映画なんじゃ
ないかというふうに思ったからです
でどこにかそういう映画作りができないかなと思って僕はまず映画の作り方の分析から
始めました
従来の映画っていうのは監督がいて来プロデューサーがいて彼らが考えて帰宅みたいの
があってそれに応じていろんな人が集められて
でその風に役割がだんだん固定化してって会がつくられるんですね
でこのやり方が僕なんかちょっといけないんじゃないかなというふうに思って僕はその
役割はもうちょっと違う形にできないかな
英語を作る関係性を変えられないかなというふうに思いました
まずその時に僕が考えたのは映画のイメージ
土井映画を作りたいということからみんなで集まって話し合って共有していくそういう
ことを大事にしたいなと思いました
で作られたイメージからだんだんと役割がしまっていく役割があって映画作れるんじゃ
なくて
イメージがあってそこから役割をしまっていく
そういう役作りをやろうと思いました
それがデイドリームシアターの立ち上げたたちのやりたかったことです
でこのデイドリームシアターで a を作り始めるんですけどまず1猫映画を作ったか
というとそうではなくて
スタジオ作りました
なんで映画じゃなくてスタジオを作ったかと思うと思うんですけど
当時デイドリームシアターには社会人で働いてる人だったり
僕大学生だったんですけど no 中世の学生たちが動いてなかなか自分たちのこの
時間をすり合わせて集まることが難しかったんですね
集まれないと去っていったようにイメージの共有ができない
だからまずこう集まれる場所を作ろうそういうふうに思いました
それでスタジオ作るところから僕らの映画を始まりました
でこうやってスタジオ作ってそこで映画作りが始まるんですけどど映画を使ったかと
いうと
彼らですね彼らはと北海道の串のニュルミュージシャン達です
彼らと一緒に映画を作ろうと思いました
なぜ北海道の人たち試写会がを作ろうかと思ったかというと僕が以前
北海道の釧路で内免たリーを制作したことがあったんですね
このドキュメンタリーを制作するときに出会った彼らとなんか面白そうじゃんスウェー
がづくりーじゃんって言って
会が作りが始まりました
そうやって作った映画がすごいものができるんじゃないかなと思ったんですけど結果的
にはどうなったかというと大失敗に終わったんですね
本当に無残にも
例えるなら
まだンっているつまりがメガンテになってしまったみたいな感じだったんですよ
ちょっとよくわからない方がいると思うんですけどマダンテっていうのはドラゴン
クエストっていうテレビゲーム出てくる呪文なんですねで自分のマジックポイント
魔法ポイント全部つ取り込んで敵にぶつける
すごい最大の攻撃の呪文なんですよそう
ことを映画でやろうとしたんですけど結果的にはメガンテになってしまったんですね
メガンテって何なのかというとこれは自分の hp
ライフポイントを聞きに全部注ぎ込んでぶつける
つまりここなんか自爆みたいな
ボロボロにターンて弾け飛ぶみたいな
そういうことにが落ちてしまいました
なんでその眼眼とな状態になってしまったかというとそれは
デイドリームシアターの映画の作り方に原因というか由来がありました
どういうことかというと
イメージの上映がもう凄い難しいんですねこれ
スタジオとか作って集まってもなかなか潮流できない
しかもこの時は勝ったことが北海道で暮らす彼らと東京で暮らす僕らの間では例えば
ある言葉を一つとってもその言葉の背景にあるイメージとか
文脈っていうものが全然違うんですよ創造汁物が全然ちがだから何かイメージを共有し
ショートしたときにそのセリア者が難しくて段々と
プレみたいな分までしまう何か大手違いみたいなものが生まれてしまったんです
このことは僕の中ですごく大きな問いとして残りました
この時についたあだ名が
これ悪魔たがあったんですよ
すごい当時
なんか嫌でしたね
だ泊またってなんか暗い感じがするし
ダークとかなんかものすごく子ダークサイドみたいな
やばいなーみたいな映画も失敗してるしものすごい高世界とすれ違ってる感じがして
どうやって生きていけばいいんだろうと思う
これはまずちょっと状況を変えなきゃいけないそういうふうに思って社会性の獲得を
もか目指して就職しました
ありがとうございますこんな僕でもなんとか就職できたんですね
で就職した会社というのは映像の制作会社でした
そこでは映画だったりテレビドキュメンタリそういうものを制作していました
だけれども
そこでもなんか上手くいかなかったんでしょで
なんて言われたかというと人間の気持ちが分からない
こういうことを働き始めてからしばらくた時に同時期に複数の人から僕は言われました
人間の気持ちがわからないって人間にいうことじゃないと思うんですけど
なんかなかなかそんなことは言わないですよねで僕もへ
社会性の獲得とか言ってるけどそれどころじゃないじゃんでの腕人間の気持ちは考え
ようだと思って野菜なぁ
さすがにちょっと自分自身をこう見つめ直すそういう時期でした
でもこのことがきっかけで僕はあることに気づきました
それが循環循環ということです
僕はあたらいてみて気づいたんですけど同じ場所に留まって同じ作業をするみたいな
ことがすごく苦手だったんですね
周りの崇敬が変わっていけば僕は耐えられるんですけど
久我していた仕事はデスクワークだったのでそういうことがあまりなかった
彼と僕自身
話しながら考えをまとめるタイプなんですねでこれはよく怒られると思うんですけど
ちゃんと考えをまとめてから話せみたいな
でもぼく離せないと考えがまとまらないんで
そういう風に言われると何も考えられないですよで黙ってるとまた怒られる女だよ
どっちでもさなんか怒られるみたいなすごくそういう状態がありましたでもこう話し
ながら考えるとか何か風景が国中で自分をこう
落ち着かせていく集中させていく自分にはそういう動きが大事なんだ
そういうこと思って
何か
その循環のある官庁を自分で整備していけなくてはいけないそうゆうこと思いました
でダークマターということも嫌ではあったんですけど自分のその性質だと思って1回
そのダークマターであることを受け止めて自分の周りを書いていこう
自分自身を変えていこうそういうふうに思いました
そこでまたデイドリームシアターの活動を再開させます
デイドリームシャッターを活動を再開させてまず行ったのが北海道の釧路でした
なぜ9種に行ったかというと以前製作した映画で後ろという場所は僕の中で大きな遠い
として残ってたからです
何かそこに歩こう違いというか僕には分からないものを
映画を作ることでもう1回捉えてみたいそういうふうに思っていきました
ただ今回の映画作りでは僕に分からないものそれをリサーチするそういうことから
丁寧にやっていこうというふうに思いましたイェイ
そのようにこう北海道釧路でリサーチを進めていく中で段々と
その土地にある課題とか問題自分のチームが抱える課題とか問題
そういうものに気づいていきました
そこで見えてきた問題っていうのは土地後よくやくせん申請メンタリティーみたいな
ものをどうやったら抽出できるんだろう
その方法どうすればいいんだろうそういうことだったり映画を作るときに文化的な
ネットワーク
制作地番がいそうなんですけどそのどう構築したいんだろう
そういうことが課題として見えてきました
そういった課題に対応するためにどうしたかというと僕には僕一人だけではそういう
ことはできなかったんですね
そこでそういう一茶8が得意な人をチームに入れたりすればお金が必要だ
そのたらそういうお金を作ることができる1チームに入れたりっすそういうふうにして
チームを編成してきました再編成してきました
宇多田
暗黒物質的なことを意識してチーム編成していたので
ダークサイドに落ちない51王様だって書いたんですけどそういうポジションの人も
チームこの時は入りました
時々チェックしてもらうみたいなそういう感じです
そんな風に映画をつくっていく中で北海目標である方と出会えました
その方は大学の教授先生をされている方なんですけれど
彼は僕らと話していく中で
北海道の副賞という形は何か何もないんだよね終わってるんだよねみたいなことを
すごくしにからぬ
入っていたんですね
でなぜ彼がそう思ったかというと彼はアーティストでもあってクリエイティブな捜索を
してたからそういうことを待ちに対して働きかけた時に何も小動きがないリアクション
がない
繋がりが生まれないおっそういうことのまあ半ば諦めていたというかショックを受けて
たんです
でもオクラのそういろんな可能性があるそのチームメンバーとかと話していくうちに
まあなんかお互いの持っている特性と特性を接続すればこういうことができるんじゃ
ないか
そうしたら後ろにあると文化的なネットワークとかも構築できるんじゃないか
そういう青写真みたいなものが描けるようになりました
その中で彼はすごくポジティブに何かおもしろいことを企み得るかもねーみたいな感じ
で
今僕らに
働きかけてくれるとか一緒に活動するそんな形になっています
そんな風に制作を進めていく中でデイリーのシャッターというチームの
なんか可能性みたいなものが僕は命令をな気がしたんですね
何なのかというと
僕らばー映画を作っているんです
ただ今皆さんちょっとお話聞いてだんだんを削りかと思うんですけど
映画作ってるって言ってるけど映画できてないじゃん
1個2個映画形にならない
そうそれが僕らのチームの
今の現状というかリアルなところなんですねでもその見えない映画形にならない映画
ってものを観測しようとするそれを捕まえようとす
その中でなぜか循環が生まれていくんですね
映画というものを作ろうとして働き掛けるその中でそのプロセスに台が出てきた課題
それで問題そのものにアプローチしていくと
チームが再編されたりその土地の人と関わりが生まれたり
スウェットネットワークとか術が構築されてきました
このすごく僕は不思議なことだなというふうに思っています
そう考えた時にこの映画を作ることは何か
見えないものを観測するようなことそういうことなんじゃないかなと思う
ました
これ何かにちょっと似てるなぁと思ったんですね
それが
暗黒物質だったんですよ
お高くなったという見えないものを観測するそのことと僕らが思い描いている映画って
ものをつかまえ図鑑スクするってことは何か僕の中で重なってきたんですね
その音
ダークマターと嫌だなぁと思ったのもなんだかポジティブに受け止められるようになっ
てきました
そこで僕が皆さんの今日お伝えしたいのは
それぞれの中にあるそういうダークマターみたいなものを指導を見つめてみてはいかが
でしょうか
ということです
そしてそれを観測しようとするともしかしたら自分自身や自分の周りが何かちょっと
ずつ変化していくのかもしれないな
そういうことが僕が今持っていることです
ください
あっちょっと無理ですそして最後に付け足しなんですけど
でこの僕がやってきたそのデートにおっしゃったというのは
曼荼羅だったんじゃないかなって今持ってるんですね
曼荼羅て何かというと
いろんな固執帳とかで宇宙を映画いたからをしたものなんですね
この曼荼羅もしくはチームを更新するってことはマンダの更新するそういうことだった
んじゃないかなと思います
この漫画等には名前があるんですけど体が半分機会になっても僕らにしかやれないこと
をやるよーっていうそういう名前があります
最後にちわみなさんとこのまんだろ見つめてみたいなと思います
[拍手]